the White House cranking up the spin
cycle after a whirlwind 24 hours for
America's foreign cash guzzling father
son Duo Republicans officially launching
their impeachment inquiry into President
Biden and Hunter playing a risky game of
contempt chicken blowing off a
congressional subpoena team Biden
spewing out the talking points spewing
spewing
wow they've come up with not a single
shred of evidence of any wrongdoing of
any kind by President Biden yet there
storming ahead with this impeachment
stunt anyway to please their far-right
base and play politics and it really
cheapens what is a historically grave
constitutional remedy of Last Resort
there is no evidence that the president
has done wrongdoing there's none
absolutely none so they are wasting
their time instead of doing the work of
for on behalf of the American people
they go after the president's family and
while they claim there's no evidence
something is seriously spooking the
bidens the president has been reportedly
freaking out behind the scenes over
Hunter's criminal escapades barking like
Commander at Aid who call it an
electoral liability that same report
says Hunter's worried that he may have
to flee the country if Trump is elected
again but if they're feeling down in the
dumps the bidens can always count on the
media for some tender Lov and Care 221
people without evidence voted to launch
an impeachment inquiry Congressional
Republicans who are Trump's deao legal
team merely want to tarnish his
political opponent and make Biden and
Trump all even Steven impeachment wise
these are not serious people this is not
a serious impeachment inquiry we've seen
no evidence this is just storytelling so
patently fraudulent and meritless they
have precisely zero evidence Democrats
tried to drill down on what exactly
Biden is being impeached for and well
the well was dry it's just so
transparent that this is just political
retribution it's just they're playing
politics there is no evidence that
president Biden committed a
crime the shoe is on the other foot
Jesse you have to admit this is pretty
ballsy even for Hunter and he knows
balls uh he's I think he's kind of
emulating trump in the sense that let's
go public let's air it out so to speak
let's open that
robe please don't go there if well Trump
if he had done that he would have taken
questions from the press for an hour
Hunter read a prepared statement and
scurried to lunch what about all people
saying there's no evidence well we've
documented that so what about let's hold
10% for the bid guy they've never even
explained the email or what about when
your father flies you to Mexico you get
all these clients in Mexico and then the
Mexican clients come back to the United
States and visit the vice president at
the White House and then Hunter demands
money what about if you fly your son to
China he meets all your clients you come
back with a bag of cash and then your
dad does favors for China and then after
you leave the vice presidency you were
supposed to share an office with the
Chinese guy named dong how what is that
you're not in business or what about
when the Chinese that he's in business
with buy $23 million in diamonds and
give one of them the hunter how do we
know it's just one where are all the
rest of the diamonds or how about when
Hunter takes $1.6 million cash at of
ATMs for 3 years how do we know Joe
doesn't have cash at his house because
when the FBI looked at those documents
that he wasn't supposed to have they
wouldn't let him go into every room
certain rooms were not allowed to be
entered or how about when Joe sister
Cuts him a check for 40 Grand from the
Chinese and then the day before takes
out 50 grand in cash what is his
sister-in-law doing taking 50 grand in
cash it wasn't even Christmas tip time
so these are like simple things that in
an inquiry you'd want to ask why are
they doing that why is Hunter Biden
copied on all of Joe Biden's Ukraine
emails when he was vice president and
why would the vice president use an
alias isn't that strange why are the
bidens going to St Croy year after year
after year A notorious tax shelter why
is Hunter Biden paying for his father's
phone line for eight years and why is
using burner phones none of that makes
any sense it's not that Joe Biden wasn't
involved Joe Biden is at the center of
this is his name really Dong Dong D Mr
dong d o what Dong Dong what is with
Hunter and dongs I don't know all right
Jessica that was a lot of a lot of
serious allegations that was a I would
call that a long
list serious infractions I don't think
you have a response for that do you care
to pass
no Professor I'm going to collect my
$200 and keep going around the board um
yeah it was a lot of stuff and I hope
that all of it gets addressed I I I
realize that I have been derelict in my
duty that I should begin every statement
with if President Biden is found guilty
of whatever high crime and misdemeanor
they say they have him on though none of
them can name it then democrats should
abandon him is not a cult he is the
leader of our party is the President we
like him but he's not above the law just
like Donald Trump shouldn't have been
above the law but the segment was
premised on this idea of the Democrats
are out in full force doing a spin cycle
MH but we're not we're actually seeing
Republicans themselves admit that
there's nothing to this James comr again
on this morning with Maria bomo I guess
he switched over to fbn because he
scared of Steve Ducey um ONN he said he
told old song it's from two nights ago I
know I've read it three times of
different media Outlets you should
expand your reading perview and thank
you yes Professor is just fine so James
comr then this guy Congressman green who
said if we don't go down this
impeachment route the Maga base will
stop voting for us that doesn't sound
like we have a legitimate impeachment
inquiry going that sounds like I'm
scared of being voted out and on Dana's
show this morning the two whistleblowers
were on and Bill hemmer was pushing them
they accused Biden of influence pedaling
and then didn't have anything to back it
up the story that I think will be really
interesting and it's starting to get a
little juicy definitely by Jesse's
standards is James comr and his shell
company so he's been going on for months
about the fact that people who are
innocent of these things don't have
shell companies but guess what James
comr does so he is one of the biggest
land owners 20 oh now oh oh actually's
difference between and 20 come on well
just let me if you are running I know
you majored in political science but
there's a difference I I does he have
150 suspicious wires the belittling
that's coming just emboldens me because
I know it's hurting you guys so he has a
shell company called farm team
properties that he shares with a
campaign donor was opened in 2015 his
wife is also a cone owner and it is
masking of course the fact that he owns
more land than goes on as Financial
disclosure forms if someone is trying to
run an above board impeachment inquiry
and is running around all over
television saying innocent people don't
do this thing that I'm actually doing
myself and maybe there's more maybe this
won't ever be enough for you that's
probably the case but that's something
AP report today everybody go and check
it out you still never address any of
the evidence I laid out I've said every
day the diamonds and the dongs and the
whatever diamonds and diamonds and dongs
that's a great David Bowie song all
right Zan I want to I want to do a
little call for for you uh just a media
just an interesting thing that happened
with the New York Times uh when they
were covering Hunter Biden's speech
instead of saying uh quoting him as my
father was not financially involved in
my business the New York Times quoted it
as my father was not involved in my
business I know they completely altered
what he said and it was what originally
at like 9:26 a.m. it took them hours
later to put the financially part back
in it but they never corrected it they
never had you know sometimes they have
that little Aster yeah with the
correction what happened to the New York
Times it used to be the paper of record
now it's an advocacy newspaper and you
know the people that work there if the
opinions are not what they believe they
throw themselves and start crying on the
floor like 12y olds I it's it's very
disappointing to see the New York Times
not cover this properly it's weird
though by admitting it they just drew
attention to it maybe that was part of
the strategy Dana here's you know so you
hear this backstory Joe's freaking out
Hunter thinks he's going to have to
leave the country friend of mine posited
this theory if you if you want to throw
the Dems into chaos Trump should promise
to Pardon them and just see how much
pressure would be applied to Joe to step
aside but you'd end up with jender Nome
so what do you do I've actually had a
similar thought today that if one of the
things that you could do is say I will I
will pardon Hunter but this
investigation should go on at least at
least that gets to the truth Joe like
you won't have to worry about it if
you're not president anymore in January
of 2025 I'll paron him that Trump could
say that we'll see I think that the
other thing that's happening is
President Biden's numbers are so low I
think was it galloper Pew that came out
today had him at 33% approval that's
just historically low for an incumbent
running for a reelection and what people
can grasp is that this is fundamentally
unfair what Hunter Biden kept saying
yesterday is that I'm being targeted
because my dad is the president MH
actually you were not targeted for so
many years and got so many passes for
things that you should have been busted
for because you're the president's son
but now it's all come home to Roose
because they were doing these things
that make you think well obviously if
you go through Jesse's list um it it
makes a lot of sense the other thing is
I think on the coms front Hunter is
taking a page out of Trump's Playbook
because he wants people to know like
I'll fight M so okay I'll fight even if
I might go down I might I will go down
swinging what's Curious to me is that
why would why would you hitch Eric
swalwell to Your Wagon like he took him
with him everywhere yesterday so is that
where your communication strategy is
coming from weird China I had thought of
that yes the China connection he didn't
know about Fang Fang exactly an idiot
that's the problem all right maybe the
Republicans should copy the D yes I
believe so and hire a veteran ABC
producer to do the impeachment like they
did with January 6 they wouldn't do it I
know hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else